STANLEY CUP WINNING HEAD COACH,
AND WE'RE UNDER WAY., RANKED NI
AN IT THERE FOR A
BREAK AWAY, SCORES
HIT THE BRAKES
THERE, AND THE NEUTRAL ZONE.
>> Ranan BY
FOREHAND SHIMMY.
BONINO, AND NOW MEGNA, DBONN
BACK
UNDER PRESSURE, AND GETS IT COR
IN THE NET, AND SCORESE AND YOUO
THE THIRD PERIODODGAUDREAU, AND.
>> RandyHAS A SEAM NEW
TO GET A LONG TOUCH.
HERTL, BACK FOR BARABANOV.
GETS IT TOK,A LITTLE SAUCE OUT
GAUDREAU, AND BACK TO TKACHUK,
AND GOING TO FACE A PLAYER OUT
HIGHER AND H
VLASIC DELIVERED IT.S IT BACK,
VLASIC, AND OPENS IT
ANKARLSSON KEEPS IT IN, AND
THE PIVOT, OPEN SHOT, AND OFSAIR
THSTICK,
THAT IMO
MEIER ON A PLAY OUT FRONT, A
>> Randy: WELCOME BACK TE PLAYEY
GAME
>> Bret:S FERRARO.
AND THEIR SCORE!
>> Bret: TREVOR LEWIS, A NICE
DEFENSIVE PLAY THERETHAT
OUT. WIDE, AND THE
KARLSSON AND THE PASS HERE, IT
GOES OFF THE END